a charge that
opened a path but with confrontation
the peace breached it was an all-out
fight
protesters determined to march on their
own terms into the national capital
this is an absolute confrontation
between the two sides
there is there is absolute mayhem here
they have breached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
and and that is people who are fighting
with sticks they are confrontational and
there is
absolute a tense sort of situation
in the farmer's
[Applause]
as thousands breached the barricades
the police had to retreat some got
injured
many were trapped and fled
[Applause]
the 60-day peaceful protest ended as
violence took over the streets
we are fighting for our existence if
this laws will come out in existence
farmers had promised a tractor parade
and that they did
thousands marched into delhi defying
orders of a predetermined route
they made their way to the iconic red
fort where they unfurled their flag
a symbolic moment in this resistance
[Applause]
the country celebrated its 72nd republic
day today
prime minister modi attended the parade
shortly after
and a few miles away this defines
one of the biggest challenges for his
government in recent times
neville lazarus sky news delhi